il
[Musique]
je suis une rêveuse mes professeurs
quand j'étais petit 10 à mes parents au
fath où elle a tout le temps la tête de
liste dans les étoiles
est-ce que vous avez déjà voyagé dans le
temps et bien je vous invite à voyager
avec moi jusqu'en 1992 à cette époque je
suis une petite fille dans un quartier
de montmartre à paris
j'habite avec mes frères et soeurs et
mes parents qui ont émigré récemment du
sénégal mes parents tiennent énormément
à leur culture et souhaite nous la
transmettre
et c'est pour ça que je passe alors mon
temps libre après l'école à apprendre à
cuisiner le mafé le jass apprend l'arabe
et en fait la seule activité ludique que
j'appellerais ludique d'ailleurs c'est
d'aller à la bibliothèque à la
bibliothèque
un lieu magique et c'est là bas où pour
la première fois j'ai voyagé je suis
allé à trois avec tu lis je suis allé
visiter le chemin de traverse avec harry
potter g soit la quête du graal et je
m'entends mais toutes les nuits la tête
pleine de pays exotiques plein
d'endroits et de personnes
extraordinaires à découvrir la petite
fille que j'étais alors avait un rêve
celui de voyager et vivre des aventures
extraordinaires
malheureusement mes parents ne voyait
pas vraiment la vie comme ça pour eux je
devais vraiment réussir à l'école
devenir avocate médecin rencontré un
sénégalais me marier et bien m'occuper
de mes enfants
mais moi c'était voyager et vivre des
expériences extraordinaires que je
voyais dans mon futur est malgré tout
malgré mes contraintes financières
malgré mes contraintes culturelles
j'ai décidé de réaliser mon rêve la
première étape pour réaliser ce rêve
c'est de faire une école de commerce
afin de me sèye spécialisé en commerce
international et je voulais pas faire
n'importe laquelle
c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi l'une des
meilleures de france qu'edge et j'ai la
chance d'être prise je vous révèle un
secret j'ai dit à mes parents qu'en fait
c'est la seule école que j'avais pour
qu'il me laisse y aller il souhaitait
que je sois lui c'est une école
parisienne pour pouvoir rentrer à la
maison
et ben moi je suis allé chez cage mais
j'avais pas les moyens financiers
du coup je suis allé demander un prêt à
la banque j'étais un petit peu intimidé
dallas la banque et du coup on perd mais
accompagné est un bon gars que je sois
là la banque j'ai été accueilli par une
dame et pour lui demander le prêt est au
bout de quelques minutes elle me regarda
elle me dit avec un nom de famille comme
le vôtre je ne sais pas comment vous
trouverez un prêt sur coup j'ai pas
vraiment compris ce qu'elle me disait
j'ai pas vraiment réagi mon père non
plus et alors elle va l'ordre
commencé à me parler d'autre chose bref
rendez vous c'est terminé en fait c'est
que plus tard en racontant cette
interaction avec mes amis que j'ai
réalisé ce qui s'était passé j'ai
ressenti de la tristesse après de la
colère et enfin j'avais une batte de
détermination qui s'est propagée nous en
moi cette femme avait décidé qu'à cause
de mes origines je ne pouvais pas
réaliser mon rêve
d'entrée en école de commerce et en fait
on n'a fait qu'accroître ma
détermination
j'ai rencontré plusieurs banquiers et
avant de finalement décrocher le sésame
mon prêt et ma place au sein de quel
business school
j'ai passé trois années merveilleuses
dans c est dans cette école de commerce
et ensuite mon diplôme en poche j'ai
décidé de franchir la prochaine étape
dans mon rêve aller vivre à l'étranger
et donc du coup mon choix s'est arrêté
sur singapour
j'ai alors dit à mes parents que j'avais
trouvé un super beau job là bas et que
c'était une opportunité à ne pas rater
bon en fait j'avais pas du tout trouvé
job et c'est avec 3000 euros en poche
que et mon sac à dos que j'ai atterri
dans cette ville pas mieux et en fait
pour être honnête j'avais hyper peur
j'avais peur de pas trouvé de job
j'avais peur de ne pas y arriver j'avais
peur ne pas me sentir bien dans cette
ville est en fête au bout de deux mois
j'avais toujours pas de job malgré les
centaines de cv que j'avais envoyé les
dizaines d'entretiens je commence à me
faire à l'idée que mon rêve devrait
n'est pas une réalité
deux semaines plus tard alors que je
commençais vraiment à déprimer
je me faisais vraiment que j'avais
échoué j'ai reçu un coup de fil
j'étais pris dans une boîte
pharmaceutique en tant que chargé
événementiel alors je vous laisse
imaginer ma joie mon exaltation avec mon
rêve est devenu réalité
pendant trois ans non seulement j'ai
visité plus de 30 pays mais en plus
étaient payés pour le faire et en six
mois j'avais doublé mon salaire en
devenant exporte manager j'ai visité les
souks en iran j'ai fait un safari au
botswana j'ai vu le plus beau lever de
soleil à bhagan en birmanie j'ai
rencontré des personnes extraordinaires
et j'ai découvert surtout des cultures
incroyable c'est le moment où j'ai
réalisé une chose c'est en suivant nos
rêves que nous créons le futur je répète
c'est en suivant nos rêves que l'on créé
le futur parce qu'on en fait le futur
est tout tracé pour moi je devais avoir
une vie calme avec un mari des ans
sans une vie parfaite pour certains mais
pas pour moi moi j'avais mon rêve le
rêve de faire une vie de vivre une vie
d'aventurés de découvertes et en fait
j'ai décidé de suivre ce rêve malgré les
contraintes thérèse sans trop grand son
rêve est impossible tu ne peux pas faire
ça ça c'est pas pour toi
en fait la société et les codes nous
pousse à ne pas rêver en tout cas à
rester dans la norme
et vous savez quoi les parents sont le
plus grand tueur de rêve
leur but c'est de nous empêcher de
tomber parce que oui suivre ses rêves
c'est un défi je vais vous raconter une
autre histoire à singapour j'avais
décidé de réaliser un autre rêve créé ma
première entreprise alors avec mon
associé delphine nous avons créé
littlepeek cibox une agence
événementielle pour enfants on
organisait des anniversaires sur un
concept de boîte à thème dont s'occupait
de tout non c'est tout à la main au bout
d'un an je pars en vacances en malaisie
et au retour je suis arrêté à la douane
après quatre heures d'attenté à mener
dans le bureau d'un responsable et il me
dit alors retourner en afrique vous
n'êtes plus la bienvenue à singapour en
effet malgré mon visa valable en fait
cette personne avait décidé de mettre un
terme à mon rêve est de m'interdire
l'entrée sur le territoire
ce jour là est clairement rester gravées
dans ma tête des espoirs peur tristesse
rage en fait j'ai ressenti toutes les
émotions possibles
j'ai même pleuré pendant plusieurs jours
à cause de cette injustice puis j'ai dû
faire un choix dira au revoir à mes
rêves et rentrer à paris ou bien aller
vers une autre aventure
le destin c'est que j'avais un des
avions pour l'australie où je vais là où
vacances et du coup laventure l'appel de
la vente ira était plus forte
j'ai sauté dans cet avion vers l'inconnu
je suis arrivé dans wonder sans argent
j'avais une amie qu'elle la générosité
de m'héberger je vendais des glaces le
week-end pour survivre et finalement
j'ai trouvé un job en tant que
consultante export c'était pas super
bien payé mais en moi ça me garantissait
un visa deux ans plus tard je devenais
la directrice du commerce international
d'un grand cabinet de conseil c'est le
chiffre appartement de rêve de
responsabilité dans un domaine que
j'adore je suis même devenue experte aux
nations unies est en fait est un nouveau
rêve qui se réalisait
j'avais réussi à transformer toutes les
contraintes en opportunités et
contraintes vraiment j'en ai eu une
grosse lan
et en fait je me rends compte que
réaliser ses rêves c'est comme une
course de haies ont pas ce défi après
défi mais on doit s'accrocher pour
décrocher le fameux graal est en fait
c'est défier ses contraintes ses
contraintes pardon c'est en fait un
magnifique tremplin vers la réussite
parce que qui dit contrainte dit
créativité les contraintes ça nous
oblige à penser différemment à faire
appel à une communauté à faire de
l'effectuer à sion bon je vais être
honnête avec vous quand j'avais souvent
hyper peur peur de rater demeurer
d'utiliser des choix du regard des
autres de ne pas être à la hauteur
mais en fait la peur c'est comme d'être
au volant d'une voiture sur la route de
sa vie soit on décide que c'est nous qui
conduisons soit on décide que c'est la
peur ben moi je décide de dompter me
faire en fait de me dire que bah c'est
moi qui conduis et je relève à chaque
fois le défi à chaque fois que je le
fais en fait ça de muscle ma confiance
en moi parce que l'audace est un muscle
qui ne fait que se renforcer à chaque
fois que je passe une nouvelle étape et
du coup bah maintenant plus rien ne
m'arrête
oui savoir c'était quoi mon dernier rêve
c'était de faire un toc un télex avec
cage est en fait qu'eads a réalisé mon
rêve
pour y arriver je me suis dit qu'en fait
les rêves
plus on en a mieux c'est pluies sont
grands nus c'est mon dernier rêve après
le têt
enfin juste avant le teil en fait
c'était d'aider les autres à réaliser
leurs rêves
malheureusement quand je demande aux
gens quel est votre rêve la réponse est
non mais j'ai un super but rêve mais
j'ai pas d'argent
et moi je pense que l'argent c'est pas
la clé du succès et ça devrait pas
l'être
c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé de créer
un incubateur coopératif basé sur le
troc
le troc qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
échange de ressources sans argent parce
que je crois profondément que l'argent
ne devrait pas être la clé pour réaliser
ses rêves
c'est pour ça qu'on a créé cet
incubateur coopératif en fait nous on
est des entrepreneurs engagés à créer
des entreprises sans argent mais en
échange en bas des heures de design d
accès à des bureaux des nuits d'hôtel
enfin on a carrément enfin on a troqué
l'équivalent de 1,25 million d'euros est
en fait le troc permet de réaliser des
rêves sans argent aujourd'hui je
voudrais vous lancer un défi à vous quel
est votre rêve
mais surtout quelle étape de votre rêve
allez-vous franchir aujourd'hui parce
que la différence entre un rêve et un
projet c'est une date est cette date
c'est aujourd'hui
lancez-vous